so we just simplify all of this
silliness over here and it looks
daunting but if we take it step by step
i think it'll be pretty straightforward
so first let's just simplify the
numerator and then we'll simplify the
denominator and then we can evaluate
this whole thing so to do the numerator
to subtract these two expressions from
that expression over there we have to
find a common denominator and so let me
rewrite this so this new nut this let's
think about what our new common
denominator could be so if i'm just
going to rewrite this numerator part
right over here
i'm subtracting i'm subtracting it has
to be something that's divisible by 4 so
we have to have a 4 here
it has to be divisible by 4 and it has
to be divisible by x and it has to be
divisible by x squared well if you're
divisible by x squared you're divisible
by x
so it has to be divisible by 4 and x
squared so it has to be divisible by 4
and x squared
and so we have 4x squared 4x squared
clearly divisible by 4 clearly divisible
by x clearly divisible by x squared it's
the least common multiple of all of
these it contains all of these in it
and so
to go from 4 to 4x squared you have to
multiply the denominator by x squared so
if you multiply the denominator by
if you multiply the denominator by x
squared you also need to multiply the
numerator by x squared and so you get
x squared over 4x squared and this is
clearly these the x squared could cancel
out it would take you back to one 4. now
let's do this term to go from x to 4x
squared you have to multiply it by 4x
right that's you have to multiply by x
to get the x squared you have to
multiply by 4 to get the 4 coefficient
multiply the denominator by 4x got to
multiply the numerator by 4x so we get 1
times 4x is 4x
and then finally to go from x squared to
4x squared you got to multiply by 4. do
that to the denominator you got to do it
to the numerator so 3 times 4 is 12.
now let's let's do the let's do the
denominator here so the real denominator
of our big rational expression
so once again we need to find a least
common multiple something that's
divisible by 4 and x squared well that's
pretty straightforward it's actually
going to be 4x squared
so we're going to have 4x squared
minus something over 4x squared or
something over 4x squared minus
something else over 4x squared to make
this into 4x squared you've got to
multiply the denominator by x squared so
you also got to multiply the numerator
by x squared if you don't want to change
its value so you get an x squared up
here
and then to get this to be 4x squared
you've got to multiply it by 4 but you
also got to multiply the numerator by 4.
9 times 4 is 36. and so in our numerator
and our the big part of our number now
we can jump back up here we have our
common denominator we have our common
denominator of 4 x squared and our
numerator is going to be
x squared
x squared minus 4x
minus 4x
minus 12
minus 12. now that we had our common
denominator and then in the big
denominator of the whole thing
we have our down here we have our little
small common denominator in our
denominator
and where it's going to now we have that
it's going to be equal to x squared
minus 36
x squared minus 36
minus 36 and now we're ready to evaluate
this whole big thing so if i have
something divided by a rational
expression that's the same thing as
multiplying this times the inverse of
this so let's do that so i'm first going
to rewrite this whole thing i'll rewrite
it in yellow
x squared minus 4x minus 12
all of that over
4 x squared that's this business up here
and i'm dividing i am dividing
sorry about that i just hit the
microphone i'm dividing by
i am dividing by this right over here so
dividing by this is the same thing as
multiplying by its inverse so let's
multiply by the inverse of this
four x squared over
over
x squared minus 36
and so we can multiply them you multiply
the numerators and you already might see
something happening is that the both the
nu both the numerator and the
denominator is divisible by 4x squared
so we can just divide both the
numerators and the denominators by 4x
squared right now if we want to because
this is all going to be in the numerator
this is all going to be in the
denominator and they will cancel they'll
both turn into 1.
and even before we multiply it out we
might want to see if we can factor these
out and see if there's any common
factors so x squared minus 36 that's the
same thing as x plus 6 times x minus 6
difference of squares
and x minus 4 minus 12. that looks like
let's see x minus 6 times x plus 2
right if we just factor that x
minus 6 times x plus 2
negative 6 and 2 you take the product
you get negative 12 negative 6 plus 2
you get negative 4x so it becomes that
and so our numerator and denominator are
both going to have an x minus six in
them so we can divide by x minus six
assuming that's not equal to zero
both the numerator and the denominator
and what we're left with in our
numerator so everything else canceled
out we're just left with an x plus two i
don't even have to put it in parentheses
because it's not being multiplied by
anything else we're just left with an x
plus 2 and in our denominator we're just
left we're just left with an x
we're just left with an x plus 6.
now we have to be
we have to be careful here because once
again so if we look at just the domain
of this thing right over here if we look
at just the domain of this
it would you would say all x can be
anything except for negative six so x
x
it can be
all
real numbers all real numbers
numbers except
except
six so that's if you just took the
domain of this thing over here but if
you look at the domain if you look at
the domain of our original expression if
you look at the domain of our original
expression here it's true x cannot be
equal to 6 because if x was equal to 6
you would get 9 over 36 which is 1 4 1 4
minus 1 4 you get a 0 in the denominator
so this was part this is true the domain
cannot be equal you cannot have 6 in the
domain but you also can't have x equals
0 in the domain because if you had x
equals 0 in our original expression this
would have been undefined this would
have been undefined and that would have
been undefined and you wouldn't be able
to compute anything and so if you want
our final simplified expression to have
the exact same domain as the original
one if you want to be exactly equal
mathematically it has to have the same
domain so we could say x can can be all
real numbers except six
and
zero it also can't be zero and you know
it's not obvious by looking at this but
if you wanted this to be identical to
this has to have the same domain